-This is very exciting.
I think it's very important
for people to try new things.
Yesterday, first time ever,
you did Bikram Hot Yoga.
-Yeah, well, I did. I've never
done yoga at all before.
-Okay. And you decided to
start with hot yoga.
-Here's why. So, I was listening
to this podcast from ESPN,
like a "30 for 30" one.
-Yeah.
-About Bikram Yoga.
And it was, like, this --
in the '70s,
it turned to this whole, like,
sex cult and, like,
this weird power thing.
And I was like,
"I want to try that."
-Right.
-So...
I looked it up, and there was
one right next to the --
in the town right next to me.
So I signed up, and I went.
And when I went, the lady
who teaches the class, I said,
"I've never done any yoga
before."
And she said,
"Uh, so, for this class,
really, you just want to
survive."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-And I thought, "Well, clearly
she doesn't know me."
Because you look at me, like,
you think, athlete.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I went in there.
And, turns out,
that was very good advice,
the advice that she had for me.
-Is this a 60-minute ordeal? 90?
-Oh, no, no. It was 90 minutes.
-90 minutes.
Yeah, that's, I mean,
that requires survival
if something is uncomfortable.
-Okay. So, all right. I think
I have to stand to demonstrate.
-Okay.
-But what happened was, so,
you start with these poses
and, you know, you do stuff
like this, and I was like,
"This is easy."
-Yeah.
-And so, for the first
30 minutes, I was doing fine.
The second 60 minutes,
I, literally, I spent most
of the time doing this.
[ Laughter ]
And then by --
by the last third,
everybody was doing these
contortions, and I was doing --
this was literally what I was
doing for the last
30 minutes of the thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A survivor.
-Surviving.
-Yeah. Now, yesterday
was uncomfortably hot,
even if you weren't doing yoga.
-Right.
-We were in the 90s here.
-Because what I thought was --
my brain was like,
"Well, it's 90 degrees
outside already,
so it won't be that much hotter
in the yoga studio."
But what I didn't anticipate,
is that if it's hot outside,
the yoga studio also gets
much hotter...
-Right.
-...than it might be in, like,
February or something.
-Gotcha.
-It was -- Seth,
it was really hot.
-Was it -- When you walked in,
was your first reaction, "Oh,
I've over stepped my limits."
-No. No.
-Okay.
-'Cause I'm -- I'm --
I'm -- I'm --
I'm arrogant.
-Oh, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-I walked in and I thought,
"This isn't so hot."
-Gotcha.
-Cut to --
-On the floor sleeping. Yeah.
-Not sleeping.
-Uh-huh.
-Trying desperately
not to throw up or pass out.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
-Definitely not sleeping.
-Well, congratulations.
You're here, and you look great.
-Do you think?
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, Seth.
-You're very welcome.
We -- I've talked to you about
this before.
You were in an incredible sketch
comedy group called The State.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you were --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up for The State.
-Thanks, guys.
-You were young.
-Yeah.
-How, were you guys --
I mean, you were in your 20s,
but it was low 20s, right?
Early 20s.
-I was --
I was the youngest in the group.
And I think I was 20 or 21
when the show premiered on MTV.
-Got it. So, then, you know,
I was in sketch comedy troupes
when I was that age,
but no one ever gave us money.
Now, you have a television show.
So, there's 11 of you --
-Right.
But the difference is,
now you have a television show,
and now nobody's
giving me money.
-Right. That's true.
[ Laughter ]
But you're getting 19 a pop
over here.
So -- so, what was it like
when you guys first, being
that young and getting money,
what was that like?
-Well, when you say
getting money, I think --
we were on MTV.
I think I was bringing home
$400 a week.
-Okay.
-It wasn't like I was
rolling in it.
-Right.
-Like, what I have in my wallet
right now is almost certainly
more than I was making
on a weekly basis at MTV.
I have like 300 bucks
in my wallet.
-Yeah.
-This would have been a fortune
then.
And now, it's actually it's
still kind of a fortune.
-Yeah, really.
[ Laughter ]
It's really impressive.
So, did you guys ever make --
do you feel like you ever made
choices about how to do
your show based on being young
and even having anything?
-Well, yeah. The one thing that
I think we did really well was,
we were very tapped into,
kind of, who we were.
We were tapped into, sort of,
being, at the time,
the kind of youth market.
I mean, we were --
the comedy that we were making
was reflective of exactly
who we were.
-Right.
-It was very, kind of,
aggressive and very, kind of,
I don't know,
for lack of a better word, '90s,
whatever that means.
-Yes.
-And we were --
we were really good at that.
Like, we just,
we knew how to be ourselves,
which was great.
-And -- do you feel like --
I know I asked you this
earlier today, but your kids
don't care about this.
Do they care about that?
-No.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No.
I mean, they are barely
speaking to me at this point.
-Okay, gotcha. Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Which is fine.
They're teenagers.
That's what they're
supposed to be doing.
-Yeah, that is what
they're supposed to do.
-Yeah, I mean, it's --
it's exactly right.
I'm very -- when,
developmentally,
when they're like,
"I hate you, Dad."
I'm like, "perfect."
That's exactly --
-Where you're supposed to be.
-Right.
That's where you're
supposed to be.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much
for being back.
-My pleasure.
-It's always a pleasure
to see you.
Michael Ian Black, everybody.